Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
If
Now we are after having discussed the
conditions of wiping over the
footwear
and we mentioned that these conditions
are
essentially
number one that a person puts the
footwear on having made full wool
washing their feet. Number two, that the
individual
do not go past the allotted time, which
is one day a night for a resident, three
days, and three nights for the traveler.
As long as a person has these conditions
fulfilled, they may wipe over their
footwear. And when does that timer or
when does that time start?
[Arabic recitation]
The first time we wipe over them in
making mudoo.
And what is set by that time is not the
wudoo itself but actually the what? The
wiping itself. The woo itself can go
past that. A person could conceivably
wipe over their footwear and then have
woo for
36 hours. Right? The point is is that to
wipe again it is only 24 hours and 72
hours for the traveler.
We also mention
that the person is to wipe on top of the
footwear
and that anything that is considered
wiping is acceptable. And I also showed
you how the prophet sallallah.aii was
used to wipe it.
As for the material
of the footwear, does the material
matter in the correct opinion? No, it
does not. If it did, I want you to
imagine something.
Imagine with me the companions.
They come from all walks of life, right?
From all over the Arab peninsula and
outside. Some of them are even from
Persia. Some of them even live with the
Romans. And they had many different
things that they wore on their feet.
Correct? Some of them wore leather, some
of them wore shoes, some of them wore
socks, some of them wore obviously they
didn't all have one standardized thing
that they wore, especially given the
fact that they were so poor at the
very beginning of the establishment of
the Islamic State in Medina.
So the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam would have seen that they have
different things on their feet and
having taught them to wipe over their
footwear.
Would if the material mattered would he
have not mentioned that emphatically?
Would he have not clarified that seeing
that some of them were shoes always?
So in 10 years he would have at least
said don't wipe over shoes only wipe
over leather. At least there would be
one narration two narrations.
Right?
Second of all what about if the footwear
is damaged?
If it has a hole or if it has can a
person wipe over it or not? Again,
imagine the companions,
the women that prayed behind the
companions.
They were not allowed to raise their
head from sujud until the men were
completely standing. Why?
Because they had so little clothing on
that if the women would have raised
their heads first, they might see some
of the people in front of them might see
some of their
private parts because they were so poor.
Is it is it conceivable that they all
had pristine
footwear on, brand new, no holes, not
worn out,
perfect?
Absolutely not. Right. Not only that,
but in the battle of
and it's called the battle of the battle
of the patches or the rags. One of the
reasons it was referred to as
the battle of
is because the companions walked so far
that their shoes fell apart.
So what did they do? They ripped parts
of their clothing and wrapped their
feet.
Imagine a a mummy how it would wrap wrap
their feet in it. and they wiped over
these wraps. Did these wraps completely
cover every single part of their foot?
No. Their toes would be sticking out.
Their heels would be sticking out as a
person would be. But emphatically and
specifically
and others say we wrapped our feet and
wiped over the wraps.
Right? So if there's a hole or if there
is a a a cut or a place in the
footwear that is damaged or thin, this
won't affect it
as long as it is mostly covering the
foot. Some scholars say it has to at
least mostly cover the foot, mostly be
considered intact, right?
Another thing that is mentioned in a as
a condition of footwear that is suitable
for wiping over is that it be above the
ankles.
Now this is an issue that is debated
amongst the scholars. However, back to
our original
concept here, and that is that the
companions,
did they all have shoes and leather
socks that went above their ankles
or those wraps went above their ankles?
Every one of them? No. And so had this
been a condition we would have some kind
of narrations mentioning it especially
during Hajj. Why during Hajj and Omrah?
Why?
What is the condition of footwear in Haj
and Omrah?
Who here has been to Hajj or Omra? Who
here has been in?
Is it permissible for a person's
shoes or socks to go above the ankles?
No, it is not. The prophet sallall.aii
wasallam sawb
during
wearing a pair of
leather leather moccasins or leather
socks that were above his ankles and he
told him to cut them to below his
ankles. When a person is in haram, it is
not permissible to wear footwear that
goes above the ankles.
So now you imagine hundreds, thousands
of companions that are making Hajj with
him.
Did they wipe over their socks and shoes
or not? Definitely yes.
And were their socks and shoes below the
ankles or not? Definitely yes. And did
he tell them take your shoes off if they
are not above the ankles? Definitely no.
We don't have a single narration like
that. Which leads us to the
the opinion
it is or to the sunnah which identifies
for us that the sunnah of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam is that the
footwear it doesn't matter what material
it's made of. We heard that he wiped
over socks and shoes, leather, and all
kinds of other things. It doesn't have
to go above the ankles. It doesn't have
to be free of any imperfections. It can
have a hole or something here and there.
As long as it still retains the name of
what it is and it is covering most of
the foot, does not have to go above the
ankles.
And so these are in fulfilling the
reality of the state of being that the
companions
were in. If we open a book of some of
the fukah, especially the later faukah,
we see that they have it must be above
the ankles and it must be free of
imperfections and it must be made. This
these conditions are unreasonable for
the state of being that the companions
were in.
for
[Silence]
sir.